doivent passer par cinq étapes de croissance :
un, la société traditionnelle, où la production d'une nation est limitée
par sa technologie, ses institutions et sa mentalité ;
puis les conditions préalables à un essor,
les débuts d'une industrie bancaire,
la mécanisation du travail
et la croyance que la croissance est nécessaire à un objectif plus large,
tel que la dignité nationale ou une meilleure vie pour les enfants ;
puis l'essor, où l'intérêt composé est intégré aux institutions de l'économie
et la croissance devient la situation normale ;
quatre, le chemin vers la maturité où vous avez n'importe quelle industrie,
peu importe vos ressources naturelles ;
la cinquième et dernière étape, l'âge de la consommation de masse
où les gens peuvent acheter tous les biens qu'ils veulent
comme des vélos et des machines à coudre --
c'était en 1960, rappelez-vous.
Vous pouvez entendre la métaphore implicite de l'avion dans cette histoire,
mais cet avion n'est pareil à nul autre
car il n'aura jamais le droit d'atterrir.
Rostow nous a laissés voler
vers le crépuscule de la consommation de masse
et il le savait.
Comme il l'a écrit :
« Et puis la question ensuite,
quand l'histoire ne nous offre que des fragments.
Que faire quand l'augmentation du revenu perd son charme ? »
Il a posé cette question mais n'y a jamais répondu, voici pourquoi.
C'était en 1960,
il était conseiller au candidat à la présidence John F. Kennedy,
qui se présentait aux élections sur la promesse d'une croissance de 5%.
Le boulot de Rostow était de maintenir cet avion en vol,
pas de demander si, comment ou quand on lui permettrait d'atterrir.
Nous voilà, volant vers le crépuscule de la consommation de masse
après plus d'un demi-siècle,
avec des économies qui en sont venues à attendre, exiger et dépendre
d'une croissance éternelle
car nous en sommes financièrement, politiquement et socialement dépendants.
Dépendants financièrement car le système financier actuel
est conçu pour viser le taux de rendement monétaire le plus élevé,
mettant sous pression permanente les sociétés cotées en bourse
pour avoir des ventes, des parts de marché et des profits croissants
et car les banques créent de l'argent avec des dettes portant intérêt,
remboursées bien plus cher.
Politiquement dépendants
car les politiciens veulent plus de recettes fiscales
sans augmenter les impôts
et qu'un PIB croissant semble être un moyen sûr d'y parvenir.
Aucun politicien ne veut perdre sa place dans la photo de famille du G20.
(Rires)
Mais si son économie arrête de croître alors que les autres continuent,
il sera éjecté par la prochaine puissance émergente.
Socialement dépendants de la croissance
car, du fait d'un siècle de propagande consumériste,
qui, de façon intéressante, a été créée par Edward Bernays,
le neveu de Sigmund Freud,
qui a réalisé que la psychothérapie de son oncle
pouvait être transformée en une lucrative thérapie par les achats
si l'on pouvait nous convaincre de croire que nous nous transformions
à chaque fois que nous achetons quelque chose de plus.
Aucune de ces dépendances n'est insurmontable
mais elles méritent toutes beaucoup plus d'attention qu'on ne leur accorde,
regardez où cela nous a menés.
Le PIB mondial est 10 fois plus élevé qu'il ne l'était en 1950
et cette augmentation a engendré la prospérité de milliards de gens
mais l'économie mondiale est également devenue incroyablement clivante,
avec la plupart des rendements monétaires
accaparés par une fraction du pourcent de la population mondiale le plus riche.
L'économie est devenue incroyablement dégénérative,
déstabilisant rapidement cette planète à l'équilibre fragile
dont toutes nos vies dépendent.
Nos politiciens le savent et offrent de nouvelles destinations à la croissance.
Il y a une croissance verte, inclusive,
intelligente, résistance, équilibrée.
Choisissez le futur que vous voulez tant que vous choisissez la croissance.
Je crois qu'il est temps de choisir une ambition plus grande et importante
car le défi de l'humanité pour le XXIe siècle est clair :
subvenir aux besoins de tout le monde
avec les moyens de cette planète extraordinaire, unique et vivante
afin que nous et le reste de la nature puissions nous épanouir.
Le progrès sur cet objectif ne sera pas mesuré par la métrique de l'argent.
Il nous faut un ensemble d'indicateurs.
Quand j'ai essayé de représenter ce à quoi cela pourrait ressembler,
aussi étrange que cela semble,
cela s'est avéré ressembler à un donut.
Je sais, je suis désolée,
mais laissez-moi vous présenter le seul donut
qui pourrait s'avérer être bon pour nous.
L'utilisation des ressources par les humains rayonne depuis le milieu.
Ce trou au milieu est un endroit
où les gens manquent de biens de première nécessité.
Ils n'ont pas la nourriture, les soins, l'éducation,
la voix politique, le logement
dont chacun a besoin pour une vie de dignité et d'opportunité.
Nous voulons sortir tout le monde du trou, vers une assise sociale
et ce donut vert.
Mais, et c'est important,
notre utilisation collective des ressources
ne peut pas dépasser le cercle extérieur,
le plafond écologique,
car nous faisons tellement pression sur cette planète extraordinaire
que nous la détraquons.
Nous causons des dérèglements climatiques, acidifions les océans,
créons un trou dans la couche d'ozone,
dépassant les limites planétaires
des systèmes indispensables à la vie qui, les 11 000 dernières années,
ont fait de la Terre une demeure si favorable à l'humanité.
Ce défi à double tranchant pour subvenir aux besoins de tous
avec les moyens de la planète,
il invite à une nouvelle forme de progrès,
non plus cette ligne de croissance toujours en hausse,
mais un juste équilibre pour l'humanité,
s'épanouir dans un équilibre dynamique entre les fondations et le plafond.
J'ai été frappée, une fois cette représentation créée,
de réaliser que le symbole de bien-être dans de nombreuses cultures anciennes
reflète cette même notion d'équilibre dynamique,
du takarangi maori
au yin yang taoïste, au nœud sans fin bouddhiste
et à la double spirale celtique.
Comment pouvons-nous trouver cet équilibre dynamique au XXIe siècle ?
C'est une question clé
car, comme le montrent les parts en rouge, nous sommes loin de l'équilibre,
nous sommes trop bas et trop haut en même temps.
Dans le trou, vous voyez que des milliards de gens dans le monde
ne satisfont pas leurs besoins les plus fondamentaux.
Pourtant, nous avons déjà dépassé au moins quatre limites de la planète,
risquant de détraquer le climat de façon irréversible
et l'effondrement de l'écosystème.
C'est l'état de l'humanité et de notre planète mère.
Pour nous, les gens du début du XXIe siècle,
ceci est notre selfie.
Aucun économiste du XXe siècle n'a vu cette représentation,
pourquoi imaginer que leurs théories
pourraient relever ces défis ?
Il nous faut nos propres idées
car nous sommes la première génération à voir cela
et probablement la dernière ayant une chance de changer l'histoire.
Les économies du XXe siècle nous ont assuré
que si la croissance créait l'inégalité,
pas besoin de la redistribuer,
plus de croissance équilibrerait les choses.
Si la croissance crée de la pollution,
pas besoin de la réguler, plus de croissance dépolluera.
Sauf qu'il s'avère que ce n'est pas le cas
et que ce ne le sera jamais.
Nous devons créer des économies résolvant ce déficit et ce dépassement ensemble,
conçues pour cela.
Il nous faut des économies régénératives et distributives par nature.
Nous avons hérité d'industries dégénératives.
Nous transformons les matières de la Terre en ce que nous voulons,
les utilisons un peu, souvent qu'une fois, puis nous les jetons
et cela repousse les limites planétaires,
nous devons incurver ces flèches,
créer des économies qui fonctionnent avec et au sein des cycles du monde vivant
afin que les ressources ne soient jamais épuisées mais réutilisées,
des économies solaires,
où les déchets d'un processus alimentent le prochain.
Ce genre de conception régénérative apparaît partout.
Plus d'une centaine de villes à travers le monde, de Quito à Oslo,
de Harare à Hobart,
génèrent déjà plus de 70% de leur éléctricité
avec le soleil, le vent et les vagues.
Des villes comme Londres, Glasgow et Amsterdam
sont à l'avant-garde en termes de conception de ville circulaire,
trouvant des moyens de transformer les déchets d'un processus urbain
en alimentation pour le prochain.
Du Tigré, en Éthiopie, à Queensland, en Australie,
les fermiers et les forestiers régénèrent des paysages autrefois arides
afin qu'ils regorgent à nouveau de vie.
Tout en étant régénératives par nature,
nos économies doivent être distributives par nature
et nous avons des opportunités sans précédent pour mettre cela en œuvre
car les technologies et institutions centralisées du XXe siècle
ont concentré les richesses, le savoir et le pouvoir dans quelques mains.
Ce siècle, nous pouvons concevoir nos technologies et institutions
pour distribuer les richesses, le savoir et l'autonomie à beaucoup.
Au lieu des énergies fossiles et de la fabrication à grande échelle,
nous avons des réseaux d'énergie renouvelable,
des plateformes numériques et des imprimantes 3D.
200 ans de contrôle de la propriété intellectuelle par les entreprises
sont bouleversés
par l'approche ascendante, open-source, en pair-à-pair des biens communs.
Les entreprises cherchant encore le taux de rendement maximum
pour leurs actionnaires
semblent soudain dépassées
face aux entreprises sociales conçues pour générer
de multiples formes de valeur et les partager dans tout leur réseau.
Si nous pouvons exploiter les technologies actuelles,
de l'IA à la blockchain,
l'internet des objets, la science des matériaux,
si nous pouvons les exploiter au service d'une conception distributive,
nous pouvons assurer que les soins médicaux, l'éducation,
les finances, l'énergie, la représentation politique
atteignent et autonomisent ceux qui en ont le plus besoin.
Une conception régénérative et distributive
engendre des opportunités extraordinaires pour l'économie du XXIe siècle.
Où cela mène-t-il l'avion de Rostow ?
Pour certains, il porte l'espoir d'une croissance verte éternelle,
l'idée que grâce à la dématérialisation,
la croissance exponentielle du PIB peut durer infiniment
alors que l'utilisation des ressources diminue.
Mais regardez les ressources. C'est une vue de l'esprit.
Nous devons dématérialiser nos économies,
mais la dépendance à la croissance
ne peut pas être découplée de l'utilisation de ressources
à l'échelle nécessaire
pour nous ramener à bon port dans les limites planétaires.
Cette façon de voir la croissance est inhabituelle,
la croissance, c'est bien, non ?
Nous voulons que nos enfants grandissent, que nos jardins poussent.
Regardez la nature et la croissance est une source de vie merveilleuse et saine.
C'est une phase, mais beaucoup d'économies comme l’Éthiopie et le Népal
sont dans cette phase.
Leurs économies sont en croissance de 7% par an.
Regardez à nouveau la nature
car des pieds de vos enfants à la forêt amazonienne,
rien dans la nature ne grandit éternellement.
Les choses grandissent, grandissent et arrivent à maturité
et ce n'est que ce faisant
qu'elles peuvent s'épanouir pendant très longtemps.
Nous le savons déjà.
Si je vous disais que mon amie était allée chez le médecin
et qu'elle avait une excroissance,
cela sonnerait différemment
car, intuitivement, nous comprenons que quand quelque chose croît éternellement
dans un système sain, vivant et qui s'épanouit,
c'est une menace à l'ensemble de sa santé.
Pourquoi imaginerions-nous que nos économies
seraient le seul système pouvant inverser cette tendance
et s'épanouir avec une croissance éternelle ?
Nous avons urgemment besoin d'innovations financières, politiques et sociales
qui nous permettent de surmonter la dépendance structurelle à la croissance
afin que de pouvoir nous concentrer sur l'épanouissement et l'équilibre
au sein des limites sociales et écologiques du donut.
Si l'idée même de limites vous fait vous sentir limité,
réfléchissez-y à deux fois.
Car les personnes les plus ingénieuses au monde
font des limites la source de leur créativité.
De Mozart sur son piano à cinq octaves
à Jimi Hendrix sur sa guitare à six cordes,
Serena Williams sur un terrain de tennis,
ce sont les limites qui révèlent notre potentiel.
Les limites du donut révèlent le potentiel que l'humanité a de s'épanouir
grâce à une créativité, une participation, une appartenance et un sens sans limites.
Cela va nécessiter toute l'ingéniosité que nous avons pour y arriver,
alors allons-y !
Merci.
(Applaudissements)